it's going live gonna live switch it
Bonjour Madame imam moussa je m'appelle
Justin Jim Appel Pierre
oh yeah that's welcome to Paris that's
the extent of the the French that I know
so today is the Paris games week Sony
Playstation 4 press conference I'm
Justin hey Walden I'm joined by Peter
Brown hey yeah we're gonna be breaking
down what things we expect to see out of
this because we know that it's gonna be
a big show sony has already said that
there are going to be seven new games
here yes and those could be big those
could be small we're assuming there'll
be something big because they're even
saying that the pre-show is a big deal
at least today being the people on
Twitter who might know things that we
don't well like so I think the way that
they've said that this is gonna go out
is at 8 o'clock 8 a.m. Pt here in San
Francisco they're gonna start off with
just here are the new games it's gonna
be an hour's long rundown of seven new
titles and then the hour after that
they're gonna kind of go into a deeper
dive into some of those titles and two
other stuff that it's coming up maybe
stuff that we already know about but I
think the seven things that we're gonna
see are primarily gonna be new IP
they're probably going to be stuff that
we haven't heard of before and I think
there's gonna be a big focus on
PlayStation VR yes if Tokyo Game Show is
any indication last month in September
pretty much everything Sony had to show
that was new was VR related in some way
and there were some interesting things
in there not all of them Sony made of
course we had something like a zone of
the enders VR which was a huge surprise
a bit of a letdown as well once we got
to the show floor and actually had our
hands on it but you know we also saw
some other games there including
something known as the impatient which
would be the prequel to until dawn if
you remember that was the sort of horror
movie choose-your-own-adventure type
thing and now it's getting a VR prequel
that I don't know a whole lot about but
it's supposed to be set I think like 60
years prior 40 years prior well I don't
know how you do that but the thing
that's that's interesting to me on this
is that VR has launched in 2017 like
this has been the official year of VR
but we really haven't heard anything
about it like oculus has had their full
headset HTC vive has had their headset
PlayStation VR has been on the market
well we really haven't gotten a lot of
games there still hasn't been that
killer app there still hasn't been that
that buzz around it like yeah the people
regular people I who I talk to don't
talk about VR is something that they're
even conscious of it's true I think
there was a really big push for a while
there and like you know everyone sort of
bought their headsets and I don't really
know anyone who's buying or considering
to buy a headset at the moment right it
was all around launched in 2016 we are
seeing some price drops as well like I
think I think the vibe is now like
available as a bundle for the same price
as it was brand-new with certain games
I'm also seeing the PlayStation VR go
for about $300 which is cheaper than it
was what did it launch that was at 4 or
5 I think it was close it was almost the
price of a full Playstation right it was
like $400 but then you also had to think
you need the camera you need the weird
controllers they move controllers the
controllers ya know so like one of the
big issues is that there are almost
always gonna be in YP s because you
can't just have existing games and just
throw them to VR as much as like those
are the games that we we won that we
understand that doesn't necessarily work
when you just try to translate at 1 for
1 in VR except for Resident Evil 7 which
was a pretty amazing VR experience yeah
so looking at zone of the enders right
now it's a pretty good example of a game
that maybe is struggling to translate
you know what made a decent into a VR
experience you'd think a first-person
cockpit view controlling a mech would
work well and and I think so many of
these I know we have and I think you
know the one thing that this game has
going forward as sort of the art and the
world behind it but when I played it the
controls were not that great they
weren't that responsive they were very
context-sensitive and sort of the game
telling you when that context shifted
and when certain controls applied it
wasn't all there but it was also pretty
early build still surprised to see that
coming back finally 15 has its own thing
monster of the deep which is a fishing
game in VR and it shows you that you
can't just translate look I it makes it
you can't just translate you can't take
that final fantasy 15 experience put it
directly into VR so you make it a weird
mini game well there is fishing in Final
Fantasy 15 but at the same time but it's
not the crux of the game no and it's
also not a you know a super compelling
reason to go out and spend hundreds of
dollars on a VR
set well you get to hang out with these
like put on some black leather go out
fishing that's been my some previous
selfies when he's got one of those
cameras yeah I mean I think that's just
it right it's like that what is the real
draw here don't know hopefully there's
something here that can kind of I don't
know make me interested in PlayStation
VR because after thumper and after rez
to music centric experience is oddly
enough and I guess Resident Evil 7 I
can't really think of a reason to go out
and buy one well so when you saw this
set up at at Tokyo Game Show which is
some place where I would think maybe
this would catch on before it would
catch on here in the States what did it
seem like a big deal does it seem like
both Sony's putting a lot into it and
there's a lot of interest around it I
don't know if the interest was super
high a lot of the people that I saw
lining up seem to be business types and
a lot of people in the VR chairs
themselves also seem to need a lot of
help with the demos so it seems almost
like the general general gaming audience
even in Japan is maybe still a little
bit lukewarm I think there is always
that that hype surrounding launch of new
hardware and the excitement around what
is it capable of but I feel like that
time has passed
of course you know my experience in
Japan was very small just at the game
show but just you know even the demos
alone like there wasn't anything that
stood out as being super interesting it
was sort of like checking all the boxes
right they had a shooter with cover
stuff where you can duck in VR you know
we've seen that everywhere they had a
summer lesson that game from Bandai
Namco I think that so is it's kind of
weird and creepy as that gave in it's
like I did get to try that a couple
years ago I think it one of the
teenagers loved it I didn't know it is
it's like it's it's almost creepy that
that sense of presence that you get like
that someone is like leaning in close
right whispering in your ear like anime
Israel it's I thought that was a good
use of virtual reality because it's not
something that's a normal game it's not
something that I would normally
experience in a video game but it feels
like I am talking with another person
like right but that's definitely one of
those experiences that I think you sort
of pick up after the fact right it's
sort of like it well it's not the reason
well come on Justin is there anything
that would make you say like this was a
great use of Maya or do you know what
that would be like that I'm glad I got a
VR system that I want to play this at
home
not necessarily but I think to your
point you know having something like
summer lesson which is this you know
maybe not the primary reason you'd want
one but a secondary reason to sort of
put the headset on if there were more
experiences like this the the the
smaller interesting you know things that
provided a more distinct experience then
it might be more curious cuz I don't
need necessarily the big blockbuster
game right I was talking about reasons
to buy a VR headset but we're really I
think it what it is just the landscape
is just kind of sparse yeah this is
definitely not what you would consider a
blockbuster well it depends on your
taste I suppose but there's there are
definitely uses for this that that seem
like they might go beyond gaming but yes
so there's gonna be a lot more than just
virtual reality at this conference I
think that is gonna be a big part of
what Sony is gonna talk about today but
I think we're also gonna hear about some
other other upcoming gigs maybe things
we haven't heard about in a while and
one of them that I'm actually really
curious about because that's also I
think melds a little bit with the
PlayStation VR it's dreams there's a
Media Molecule
I love LittleBigPlanet is problematic as
it was from maybe the control schemes it
was such a cool quirky little idea and
now they're going in a completely
different direction with dreams and
Microsoft kind of had their own similar
title like this but where you create
your own worlds and create your own game
that one Microsoft's versions seem to be
much more let's say in Wow I'd say
intense a much higher barrier to entry I
think one of the things when they were
showing off dreams that made it so
compelling was that it was so intuitive
now maybe that was just sort of the art
creation aspect of it I don't think
we've seen actually like how you go
about animating and applying different
you know rules and and logic to these
worlds that you're creating but you know
it's almost like the I'm losing the name
of it now but on the vive headset
there's a none oculus as well they're
these various you know 3d creation apps
where you use a controller as a wand and
sort of generative sketching yeah
exactly and and that seems to be at
least what I remember of dreams you know
the ease of creation when it comes to
different models and such I would love
to see how all that translates to the
final finished product of whatever
you're creating maybe we'll see more of
that do you think this is gonna come out
like my biggest fear is that like
something we've seen so much of us and I
can't imagine it
not coming out at this point but at the
same time it seems so ambitious that I
could also see this dying that it just
is gonna be a vapor we're title I think
we'll see it come out I don't know that
we'll see it
III think it'll have the capabilities to
let people create things like this but
again this is in the hands of the
creators of dreams who are themselves
professional game creators I think what
we'll actually see is a set of tools
that are maybe simpler than what we
imagined and it won't be as robust
robust yes I think you know on face yeah
did you make a lot of levels in
LittleBigPlanet no but I liked playing a
lot of them I mean that was like there
were hundreds to choose from and it felt
like I think we were back both back a
1-up back at that time and it felt like
every day there was some new level that
was just like surprising everyone and
that was super amazing
oh yeah like it's a calculator like that
yeah like how did you come up with these
like genius ideas as a [ __ ] I possibly
imagine the math that's involved in in
these kinds of I was just busy I didn't
but yes so one of the other things that
I'm excited about that we're hearing
rumblings that we might get is
sucker-punches new IP so Sucker Punch is
the team that did infamous like blast
was infamous last light and they've been
doing a lot of infamous but solely their
ability to go beyond the infamous series
to make something new because I was
hoping it was gonna be a spider-man game
and it's obviously not in spider-man's
being handled by insomniac but so
getting a new IP from Sucker Punch is
kind of exciting third-person action
game or a romantic visual novel both
that's how I like to combine all of my
games with a slight romantic visual
novel it makes the fighting games a
little weird but view is one of my
favorite characters where do you fall in
their recent work did you play a lot of
second son in the last light not a lot
of it I enough to get a feel for it like
I love their their city traversal which
is why I think they would have made such
a good spider-man game I'm still really
curious to see what insomniac does it
but but what Sucker Punch does with
being able to get around a world is
really cool and having that that sense
of exploring kind of a real city like
they did that so well like I
with sunset overdrive I have to say but
yeah in terms of what Sucker Punch is
doing it's really anyone's guess if
they're doing anything at all yeah maybe
this will turn out to be absolutely
nothing oh and we or we just won't hear
about it here is there anything that you
think that that we're gonna hear about
so one of the rumblings I've heard is
that this is kind of taking the place of
PSX that we're not gonna get as big of a
PSX this year and in its place we're
gonna get this big Paris games week
reveals and trailers and all that so
probably more Shadow of the Colossus I'm
sure they're gonna show off some stuff
for horizon zero dawn was it called
something in the wilds president Rosen
Rose wilds that's DLC coming out next
week I do know that so of course they're
probably gonna want to advertise that
but yeah I mean the shadow of Colossus
dream master remake remaster somewhere
in there that I know like where do you
draw the line on that there's there have
been so many and so many more upcoming
like Okami
is the one that immediately comes to
mind you have a lot of these games that
are sometimes touching up a little bit
but it looks like what Shadow of the
Colossus they're touching it up a lot
it's more like more of a remake yeah
then a remaster but if it's just the
same basic game I'd be okay with that
I'd be okay with that but but I think
you know if you look at the way that
they're using the Kate wall the camera
here looks pretty traditional but a lot
of the stuff we've seen so far granted
this is a cinematic but other shots make
me think that they're reworking a lot of
the systems and I'm kind of curious if
they're if it's gonna maintain that the
floaty animations that characterize a
lot of weight as games specifically
shadows the shadow the Colossus as well
and even less Guardians so like me this
is just using the less Guardian engine
or what they put together like using
what they had with the Last Guardian and
I feel like gen design the the team that
a widow started after leaving Sony
during the development of The Last
Guardian I feel like they own that
engine but that remains to be seen but I
wouldn't be surprised if we saw more of
that and we'll probably see more of just
some of the upcoming stuff that's very
soon as we're talking about a little bit
Spider Man I think is is an obvious one
for them to show a little bit more of I
feel like they've showed a lot though I
actually want to see I don't want to see
too much more this game I'm not someone
who likes to watch trailers I hate
watching trailers for movies because I
feel like it gives away so much like I'm
the person who sits in the theater and
will close his eyes and ears so like
don't have to watch anymore thor
ragnarok be fit like I don't want it
spoiled
Oh God for Ragnarok I know it's not a
movie that you think like oh no I don't
want you to spoil it twist but they have
good jokes
I don't want those jokes to be spoiled I
want to I want to get them fresh I'm a
little skeptical about this spider-man
game I have to admit I do have a lot of
faith in insomniac but watching the
combat for this it sort of reminds me of
so many Warner Brothers type of action
games that maybe I but we'll see I
haven't played it we've really not seen
that much of it yet going in would like
Batman it just it just seems like it's
very easy to sort of you know go oh
you're alone if you don't like the
Batman game's not a favorite of mine the
idea of just sort of like jumping to and
fro just based on what the camera picks
up is your most you know near enemy
whatever simplifying it oversimplifying
it but um let's see I mean these boss
fights look good this game looks really
good if they can put it out looking like
this I'd probably play regardless now
you do have to strike that balance and
that's the when you have too much
control over what you're targeting
versus being able to just target what's
the most immediate threat yeah and
that's the thing that scares me a little
bit here is that there are so many
button prompts so it's like is it gonna
be asking me to to micromanage all this
stuff whereas I prefer that that Batman
style or shadow of war where it's like
here's your most immediate threat just
run over to it and start kicking its ass
even if that means you skate without
moving your feet how do you think Batman
gets around these with technology and
money so what else is there coming up on
the PlayStation 4 slate I liked one of
the ones that I'm excited about
but I'm trepidatious I I don't think
that we're gonna here are the square
Enix titles yeah like it's been I think
it's been a year since we've heard
anything about Final Fantasy 7 the the
remake of Final Fantasy 7 and that was
it last year right it's been a while do
you think that we would see a new
trailer for ff7 episode did they have a
new name for this yet make episode uno
no I don't know they I think this makes
sense if there's if they
really want this to be a big event
putting anything Final Fantasy seven is
a very easy way to make it a big event
even if it's not more gameplay even if
they just put in that cutscene just -
they're only gonna show cut they're not
gonna show gameplay they've they've
shown pseudo early gameplay so I you
know I don't think we're that far out
like they should some of how combat
might look like but yeah just to get
people riled up in the crowd to get the
energy up I think all they have to do is
show look put out a 30-second trailer of
Vincent doing his thing being a fancy
vampire I bet you people would be stoked
about that
yeah so here's some gameplay yeah let's
see other than that also the other big
square Enix title is Kingdom Hearts 3
right right and was hopeful about that
one hopeful like well that we're gonna
see anything I don't think we will I
feel like it's more likely that we would
see another stage or another character
in Kingdom Hearts 3 then Final Fantasy 7
as much as I I want to see Final Fantasy
7 because it's been longer Kingdom
Hearts 3 is they keep showing this off
and we have a firm release date Final
Fantasy 7 is kind of a nebulous sure
it's that card in their back pocket
though that's what would make this a
very exciting thing to show off here but
are you excited for Kingdom Hearts 3 or
you just kind of soured on the series
I'm not too interested in the series
because I don't really love Disney that
much and Kingdom Hearts never really did
it for me but I will say that Kingdom
Hearts 3 looks to be very very
impressive from a presentation
presentation standpoint and it's one of
those games where Square Enix kind of
goes off the rails a bit if you will got
it and so I'm curious to see how that
all works out what they've actually been
able to do with this game given the
number of years that's been put into it
we obviously saw a similar tale with
Final Fantasy 15 which was in
development for a little bit longer and
what it paid off it paid off I liked
what they did with that game I think the
story suffered as a result of well
actually I'm not really sure as a result
of what but I think the story wasn't
that great but I think you know the way
that they managed the open-world and the
combat to things that I really wanted
out of that game worked out really well
so you know there is a chance that
Kingdom Hearts could win me over
through its presentation and perhaps its
gameplay alone will
I'm not a huge Disney guy you are yeah
I'm serious
so the I did not expect to like Kingdom
Hearts at all because it seems like such
a stupid idea like I remember when it
first came out it going
Final Fantasy characters and Disney
characters this is dumb
it but it just felt magical like as hard
as it is to kind of go back to that
first game like I still remember that
that feeling of immersion and magic of
exploring these two worlds together it's
like magical kingdom it is it's
chocolate and peanut butter and and so
Kingdom rs3 as much as the the side
games are super weird and I have stopped
caring about the lore at all I I it's
all it's just batshit insane yeah I I
still want to play Kingdom Hearts 3 and
like getting to go to the Toy Story
world and talk with with woody and yeah
I have no affection for Toy Story Toy
Story exactly what I said I'm a
curmudgeon I'm sorry I don't know I like
give me some dark sci-fi and I'm stoked
we'll see I'm not Kira six yeah that's
dark so we'll see beyond Kingdom Hearts
beyond monster of the deep beyond final
fantasy seven what else could
square-enix possibly show us Oh No
well maybe some secret no I don't I
think I think they're not gonna focus on
multi-platform things and that one is
that's that is a game that's coming to
other platforms right that's not just
PlayStation that is just PlayStation oh
[ __ ] yeah and there's one more that they
have in the car oh the front mission
game the one that that's sort of based
in that universe I forget what it's
called but it's got Yoji Shinkawa
which is Kojima Productions artists
working for the game it's got a mech
designer from Matt cross and a few other
series working on it that looked pretty
interesting the gameplay they showed off
of that next to the cinematics didn't
look so hot a third-person action game
where rather than controlling mechs like
you would a normal front mission game
which are typically strategy titles this
is a third-person action game where
you're on foot going up against max the
the sort of list of designers sounds
more promising than anything but well
speaking of ug Shinkawa someone who's
worked with coach wright death stranding
are we gonna see deaths training because
we didn't see it we haven't seen it for
a while now right it wasn't at e3 it
wasn't at Brazil right just by Kojima
being a both
I feel like we might I think he would
hold off I like I think that this is
still like a game award show kinda yeah
yeah him and Jeff Keely go way back and
that's a very famous friendship so I
wouldn't be surprised to see deaths
training held off it's just another two
months buddy and you are someone I think
who's probably more tuned in to these
games this excitement like you you
you've good take interviewed Kojima
multiple times you is this something
that you think is gonna live up to the
legacy of what he's done with the Metal
Gear series or now that he is on his own
now that he's kind of in some ways he's
Georgia or Martin he has the keys to the
kingdom nobody's gonna tell him no do
you think it's gonna be able to live up
to what he's created ah that's very
tricky I think the a good sort of litmus
test would be to look at something like
PT because we've seen Kojima breakout
from the metal gear series before with
things like boktai and but you know zone
of the enders as well and I think those
were both products of a younger Kojima
and PT is definitely I think more in
line with the the depth of conceptual
sort of creation that I believe is gonna
be pretty heavy-handed in death
stranding I think a lot of what we see
here is not to be taken at face value
it's all supposed to be sort of
intertwined in very strange ways hence
the very dream slash nightmarish sort of
imagery that's going on here
it's very difficult to explain much of
what's happening so I think if nothing
else des training will be a very
interesting game for better or worse
that we're all gonna sort of talk about
but you know we obviously have almost no
idea about the gameplay it involves
ropes sticks but not sticks and maybe
not ropes and it's hard to know it
involves guillermo del toro in the game
itself leaving birth cody was probably
gonna be in the game too like he he's
gonna keep he's gonna put himself in
there there's a good chance maybe
walking mugger and he'll be in there his
alter ego so the the thing that's
hardest to talk about what PlayStation
is the fact that I think we're gonna get
some new IP we're gonna get stuff that
we he haven't heard of right Arthas who
you want me to make up some new IP you
know like what kind of experiences are
because yeah 2017 has been the year of
open-world games like holy crap have we
had so many massive I have I haven't
slept in in months because it's just so
many worlds to explore yeah what's 2018
gonna be cuz that's what this might set
this myth set the tone is it just gonna
be the year of action adventure and
things are gonna be gone up we're like
yeah it's tough to say I would like to
see sort of a resurgence outside of you
know the current climate and gaming
resurgence of just to focus single
player experiences Sony's always done a
pretty good job of funding and
publishing those games I just like to
see that continue you know we're
probably gonna see a lot of stuff from
other multiplayer titles like what's
that a zombie game oh oh that one no you
know the one that they showed off that
everyone was like oh yeah
the one was like tons of zombies running
at you right it's clearly like I feel
like we're gonna see zombie motorcycle
hunter some people it's like a days gone
is we're not that good at hosting are we
we're so I don't get paid for this no I
I think we're gonna see that you know a
couple games that really do support that
haber multiplayer focused hey we're
focused on big world big open worlds but
I'd really like to see some more
narrative single-player focus stuff so
yeah maybe God of War but it was last
time we even saw that I know we saw that
it III yeah we got a big demo III that
was I think they're leading stage thing
we saw a single-player aspect of it like
straight-up gameplay so like this is
something that that makes sense for for
Paris games week mmm but so we've also
seen that argument that the developers
probably want to move away from
single-player experiences like I don't
think that's ever gonna die it's not
gonna go away completely but when you
look at the the success of something
like destiny to like that that
persistent online world something that
you keep coming back to versus a
one-and-done game like god of war is
gonna be or horizon zero dawn like sure
you have the dlc and you can come back
to it for that but that's nothing like a
destiny where it's asking you to come
back every day or at very least every
week well they tried with that sudha
game that they put out with the skeleton
skateboarder dude
you know the one time I don't know I do
it come on yes you do yeah yeah look let
it die let it die my friend that's
that's sort of the you know the online
MMO ish type get your loot do your thing
and that game I know people who play it
really liked it but I don't know if it
was a huge success
so yeah the issue with having too many
of those games is that it's impossible
to have every game be that because you
just don't have time for like III don't
have a second job where I'm managing the
five other games that I'm gonna be
playing in the in the evening yeah like
you kind of have the one game that
that's gonna be your go to the thing
you're gonna be coming back to and then
I really love having these one and done
single-player experiences like I don't
know how possible it is to keep creating
games where they cost a hundred million
dollars well you'd do something like in
Hell blade you do this sort of you know
the mid tier game if you will although I
think that name is doing it a disservice
but budget wise yeah that game was not a
hundred million dollar project as far as
I'm aware and they were able to sell it
cheaply and it was a small condensed
like really interesting experience and I
think yeah people as a whole like you
and I are probably ready for more games
like that because hey it makes not only
our jobs easier but our lives easier as
well and it easier to enjoy our own
hobbies but I feel like we're missing
out you know so back in 2016 i I think
PlayStation did a big push for Indies
like that was the platform for Indies
2017 it's felt a lot more like Nintendo
sure we've gotten undertale on ps4 but
you know I'm struggling to think of what
these other smaller indie titles are and
I feel like it's not that Sony's ignore
them but they maybe haven't felt the
need to rely on them as much well do you
think that's gonna have a presence here
they've certainly opened the floodgates
on PSN I think we've seen a lot more
games just sort of pop up there and I
think it stands to reason that they're
publishing is a little bit more relaxed
when it comes to new developers now so I
almost wonder if they don't feel that
they need to rely on indie developers to
really sell their products I mean a game
like no man's sky was sort of this like
banner title that you know to an
executive well it doesn't look like
sound great on paper like what a
romantic development story but it looks
good on the screen as well and I feel
like unless Sony can really sort of sell
the power of the PlayStation through
interesting indie you know developments
they
might not focus on it too much because
they do have the xbox 1x problem right
now sort of looming overhead oh how do
you mean like just having a console that
the Xbox one access and they have a
powerful competitor coming they have a
powerful competitor coming and I think
right now messaging around their most
impressive games is probably going to be
they're the biggest selling point and
again that might mean VR because that is
something that we know the Xbox one X I
can support but doesn't really exist for
yet so and it's also something that sets
them apart like they're thinking about
this holiday thinking about 2018 I don't
feel like there's a huge differentiator
between Xbox and Playstation sure like
PlayStation has more compelling
first-party
exclusive titles but but not by a huge
margin and a lot of those that come out
already and and they're both kind of
being one up two by Nintendo they
certainly are like it's crazy to think
like a year ago that the Nintendo went
like flailing with the Wii U is now in
such a dominant position review score
wise just in IP that people are
interested in and excited about so like
what what does Sony have coming up in
2018 that's gonna mean make sure that
they maintain their places number one
because they are still the best selling
console in terms of overall numbers yeah
I don't know what that games gonna be
it's really really tough to say I don't
see a significant system seller outside
of maybe there's just me talking but
Final Fantasy 7 and death stranding
there are so many games I'm excited
about in 2018 but as far as games that
are exclusive to one console it's it's
still like my mind always comes back to
- Nintendo games like I'm really excited
about games about to destroy it to human
Justin that's I think that'll be good
like I love David cage games but like
I'll like play it III will like
definitely enjoy we know it's going to
be a little bit strange but maybe not
the thing that pushes Playstations as it
were
yeah that's not it's amazing what they
do graphics wise like that's that is a
showcase of it especially if they push
this like of the ps4 Pro and what like
that's able to do anything they're gonna
hint it may be a different model
PlayStation surely not surely not do you
do you think that the world is ready for
a nother ps4 or do you think like we'd
get the PS five and something but I feel
like that's a race that is unnecessary
at this point and well so that's the
thing it's unnecessary if you think
about it in traditional terms I think if
Sony maybe wants to adopt and Microsoft
and who knows maybe Nintendo a more
iterative model of their console cycle
we might not see this this 10 year gap
between models it might not be defined
necessarily by the number attached to
your console I personally wouldn't be
shocked I'm not saying I expect it but I
I do anticipate that the you know how
these models work and when new consoles
are rolled out will change in the near
future then it might happen in Paris
games week I think we need another week
I think another year then maybe we'll
start hearing these rumblings of the
next PlayStation but this year with
Playstation 4 Pro is already 4k capable
right it's ish yes I mean it is but it
uses certain technologies to put out a
4k image though it's not rendering
natively at 4k in most cases if not all
but I think it's just a most it's a I'm
not left wanting anything necessarily
from a Playstation it doesn't leave me I
want a port like if they're if they're
gonna announce anything I want a dock
that I put my playstation screen into
you and I pick it up man I play my
playstation games portably it would be
like a PlayStation Portable but better
there have been what there were use
rumors about a Vita - right right before
e3 yeah I just don't know well they
would never use the term Vita again and
no no but I I wouldn't be shocked if
everyone was exploring what Nintendo's
you know gone after in the aftermath
because I think it's selling really well
and you have to exploit you can't let
that go unanswered but you also have to
see like you have to think about the
decades of Nintendo's dominance in the
handheld market right nobody has been
able to crack that and the PSP did
really well for for quite a few number
of years a man mostly in Japan yes but
it didn't it even then could not quite
top on intend oh they're in that space
that's that is exciting though to think
like well what if there was another Sony
handheld and it was
something that just allowed you to play
playstation 2 for games and so like even
if it's just streaming like would you
buy a device that's just a handheld
streaming device for your PS Playstation
4 you can do that on your Vita
okay no I wouldn't buy this this is I
mean like we've seen a lot of parallels
in the Android space you know Sony
actually has pretty good support over
there for you know tablets allowing them
to stream from their their PlayStation
now service and from even your
PlayStation 4 and you can hook up
Bluetooth controllers I mean there's
been sort of like hints that's something
like that well but perhaps get more
attention down the road but it's there's
really no telling how successful has
been and I think it'd be a little
premature for Sony to get involved in a
competition with Nintendo oh you have to
start early you have to like the war has
already begun the war has already begun
huh
but I I'm actually surprised that the
services Sony has been able to continue
to offer that that I was lukewarm about
at the beginning but now I'm actually
pretty excited about like I do enjoy
PlayStation now like that it's dumb as
it seemed to stream games especially
like old ps3 games like as someone who
doesn't want to keep holding on to these
old consoles like that I can't use my
PlayStation 3 that I don't want to hold
on to these old games I kind of like
just being able to pop in and pop out of
a wide library of games on demand do you
use it often not that often but like I
don't use it every day especially like
it's hard to think about playing
anything right now that's not a game
that just came out but especially in
those fallow months like PlayStation now
was what felt really great like I was
able to catch up on Shadow of the
Colossus in eco and before heavenly
before hell-blade came out I'd caught up
on heavenly sword which was a hard game
to go back to yeah that was not agree it
reminds you that some of those early
PlayStation 3 games also do you think we
may finally get PlayStation 1 support
playstation why not there's no reason
why not god damn it come on that'll be a
new service called PlayStation every now
and every now and and that's
specifically for PlayStation Blog games
that were compatible with the
PlayStation 3 on PSN but are now just
through PlayStation every now on the
dude I'll take either or just let me put
in a disc or use a PlayStation classic
like system that would be great
I know it's worked out really well for
Microsoft in terms of like word of mouth
they they went through I felt like six
to eight months of sort of like not a
whole lot going on but people are
excited about the X people are vocally
excited at least in my circles about the
backwards compatibility like heard of
over the last week if people are putting
it through its test like it's works
pretty well so it's not bad you know and
I think that's sort of a feather in the
cap that anyone would want Nintendo is
still kind of like behind the ball a
little bit with Virtual Console at least
on the switch Sony doesn't really have
any support for old games apart from the
random ps2 classics they put out so
maybe something like this would help if
they don't you know have a whole lot to
show we'll see how big this this
presentation is yeah I mean we're gonna
get some new IPs and the thing with new
IP is that it's hard to gauge how
interesting it's gonna be because it's
like here's a new name maybe from a
studio we know maybe it's from an
entirely new studio and it's probably
gonna be here's a cutscene which is not
indicative of like well what's that
experience like but we are gonna get to
try a lot of these games out so we have
our team even though we're here we're
here in San Francisco
our team in the UK is at Paris games
week so they're gonna be playing these
things firsthand and so we're gonna be
able to give some impressions at least
of hopefully what some of these new
titles are and what they play like and
whether PlayStation VR is still
something that they enjoy flying around
with yeah you know I did have a good
time playing a Gran Turismo sport in VR
despite some strange camera placement
that actually felt really well but again
it's another one of those experiences
just like yeah I've done a lot of that
so we're gonna Sony's gonna have to go
you know pretty far out of their comfort
zone I think to get me really stoked
sooner did they change the start time
for this because I thought it was gonna
be 8 a.m. but I'm looking at the the
stream now and it says 806 which is
incredibly specific and incredibly weird
so they change it every minute bumping
it
oh no sorry we meant 809 we know Justin
and Peter there are sitting and trying
to fill time they just don't it starts
they're just enjoying watching a squirm
oh so do you want to go to Paris I have
you ever been to Paris no I'd go to the
Louvre
although I've heard the Louvre is also
disappointing other we haven't really
had a no no what that we have had an
assassin's creed set in Paris though
right you're asking the wrong guy dude I
do not play those games
you'll have to tell me because now that
we have the one in Egypt so is there
anything else in 2018 on PlayStation
that you're looking forward to
I think tip of my tongue I guess God of
War just because I have to I have to
figure out if that games gonna be good
or not because hey it's a are you a fan
of the god of war games I was just one
in two yes but I sort of fell off the
boat three was super impressive when it
came out but I never ended up playing it
I for me those aren't my favorite kind
of games like those kind of fall into
racing games which graphically beautiful
like I can enjoy watching them action
the adventure games also just kind of it
always feels button-mashing like is if
when there are things that you layer on
top of it something like shadow of war
or assassin's creed like that's a little
bit more exciting yeah but it looks like
this is starting and so you don't have
to listen to us anymore let's cut
straight over to for you we starting now
[Music]
welcome to PlayStation live from Paris
games week we've got a big big show for
you here today lots to talk about but
first I want to introduce our crew
starting with you and you've got a very
familiar face really yeah where have you
seen me before maybe the internet the
Internet yes YouTube perhaps perhaps
well you might have seen me on
PlayStation access my middle youtube
cupboard
this is a real treat to be somewhere as
diverse as this we've got like an actual
desk
lovely backdrop like this has got all
the bells and whistles you know we're
not as big-budget as they're sorry I've
got my I've got my PlayStation access
partner-in-crime with me as well Oh
Holly the amazing Holly Bennett yeah
they've also let me out of the cupboard
well this is really exciting that we're
allowed to have such fancy fancy arena
yeah for anyone who doesn't know myself
and Rob team up with three others to
make PlayStation access which is a
YouTube channel we're based in the UK
but we make content for everyone yeah
and we let you cover everything from the
world of PlayStation we eat sleep and
breathe PlayStation it's coming up next
for a Playstation access Wow anyone who
followed me on Twitter I've just come
back from Japan but it is a secret
actually we can't tell you just yet what
we were working on but very soon those
videos will be going live be very
exciting
subscribe now and rounding out our host
here mr. ramone Russell the heartthrob
you could join a spud I'm glad y'all
could have us really appreciate it yeah
like since that my name is Ramon Russell
I am from the MLB the show development
team back in San Diego
speaking of them shout out to everybody
on all our development team back at home
cranking away on MLB to show 18 we can't
wait to tell you about it but not today
today we're going to talk about all of
this awesome content come in to
PlayStation 4 that's right now tell me a
little bit about what you do with the
MLB team I know you do some streaming
tell me
little bit about that right so I do a
little bit of everything most of the
people aren't our development teams we
wear many many hats I'm a game designer
sometimes of the times I'm a community
guide other times I'm here in Paris
which you guys understates ready to see
some really awesome content and really
awesome content we are going to see
starting any minute now I want to tell
you a little bit about what we've got
lined up tonight we're gonna have 20
plus game updates we're gonna have seven
game reveals and we are gonna be
covering a wide wide spectrum it's
Triple A games we're gonna have
independent big ones we're gonna have
DLC updates or major titles big sequels
Final Fantasy updates I mean my goodness
gracious
and then the PlayStation Media showcase
and who knows what's going on there
that's just under an hour from now we've
got a lot to get to tonight and I say if
it's okay with you guys that we dive
right in the anime started off with a
reveal now this is a sequel to a game
that a lot of people really love and I
want to show the first gameplay of that
and we're gonna do that right now
after a thousand years the mask of
vengeance has manifested itself again
who will protect the Mexico's against
the powers of evil all a hero with
determination who doesn't crack under
the statue s boys of the old gods
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wacka melee to kickin this off right I
love the first game so excited to see
the drink boxes back with a sequel
coming to ps4 soonish
to come out soonish soon and we are
going to see some more gameplay of that
now-ish and this game polish you saved
that one for you did enjoy doing that
one out I kept that in my back pocket so
this game is looking super polished and
what we're seeing here I believe these
are the dimensional waves right and they
like to solve puzzles and and traverse
obstacles and you can see they're like
there's some hazards in in the red
dimension and he's safe in the blue one
also gonna add like a really interesting
anguish the puzzling now if you played
the original guacamelee you know it's
got a robust combat system and we're
gonna see a little bit of that here
juggling with those dimensional waves
but you know the the the combat in this
game is just so satisfying you've got
these luchador you know sort of pro
wrestling moves mixed up with sort of
beat him up combat and that color
palette rounding it all out and
abilities doesn't it I remember I sucked
badly at the first one here for the
chicken is bashing better than ever and
this chicken has have seen a lot of
refinement a lot of new chicken
mechanics on deck here for guacamelee
new coming to ps4 and you know they've
been spending all that time on I mean
why not yeah wouldn't you so this is
chicken here is it's quite a what a
tough customer we're gonna see that here
in a second like right now we're gonna
see a new ability unlocked by I can only
put all the chicken Oracle yeah
I swear that as a fried chicken shop
somewhere if it's not it certainly he's
telling him do not get turned into
chicken nuggets today that's right
you're gonna learn some new abilities oh
yeah is gonna get done in this chicken
chicken
this chicken shot this is a new ability
here for the chicken this chicken is
really a can-do chicken and this is
chicken shot the chicken glide we're
seeing it all here now this chicken shot
is also useful in combat so this chicken
is is a ferocious ferocious fighter
crazy melee - I love that I mean you
would not want to mess with this chicken
let me go video games are ferocious I've
learned that through my years of gaming
a murderous force be the most lethal
looking chicken I've seen there see it's
the first game play here at guacamelee -
and oh it's this co-op is this co-op ID
go up so I do have it on good authority
from drink box if there is four player
co-op throughout the entire game we're
seeing three of those four players right
now and this is the mangrove swamp level
wait for you guys to carry me rappeling
a boat mechanic here looking great Wow
great start here for tonight and you
know something let's let's let's just
keep going I got two more announcements
and we're gonna get to both of those
right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those two great new games we just got to
look at I got to say the gardens between
looking awesome it's got that art style
it's got the time mechanics Holly what
do you what do you make of that
completely my type of game I'm I'm
honestly taken with our goosebump eyes
every time that music drops
it's a beautiful single-player narrative
driven puzzle game but there's no time
pressure on the puzzles and I really
like that no text or dialogues world
tells you the story one button to
interact a lovely game to get into
genuinely in love with it and it comes
out late 2018 nice so the first trailer
that we saw that was the Hong Kong
Massacre developed by Gretzky super
stylistic trailer that looked insane it
had this like Max Payne lady run a vibe
yeah expect that coming to the
PlayStation 4 in 2018 outstanding so
we're gonna keep moving here we got a
lot to get to when frankly we're running
behind so look at Roco remastered it's
out now on ps4 we know loco Roco to
remaster is coming and right now we're
going to tell you when
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that was loco - loco loco to
remaster and that's coming out December
9th finally now we know Holly I know
this is a big one for you yeah my
bathroom is actually great with loco
Snickers she's not even joking
I loved both local games by PlayStation
PlayStation Portable yes he plays them
non-stop
I love eating and me and the local
rocker games have that in common if
you've never played local Roco before
you play this lovely little creature you
roll around you eat the flowers you get
bigger your complete puzzle sometimes
you have to be a certain size to be able
to complete them and you sing to you
know to wake up magical creatures and
when it's utterly charming by basically
love loca Roco solo Corrado - there's
gonna be new collectibles new characters
it's in 4k on PlayStation 4 bro
pre-orders start today okay so Holly I
know you're also a big fan of The Sims
yeah and I think we've got an update on
that one yes we do we know The Sims 4 is
coming to ps4 in November I'm like you
said a huge fan so we have a first look
at the expansions that are coming soon
so I say we just check it out
[Music]
that was the sims 4 it's coming out in
November on ps4 and now I have a
confession to make
I've actually never played a Sims game
yes 20 years almost I will say I did get
a chance to check it out on ps4 I spoke
with the developer and I think this
might be the one for me it's a time to
dive in so what they've done is they've
basically tried to capture the entire
Sims 4 experience from the PC and
instead of kind of reconstituting or
boiling it down or doing something else
so this is really the pure version and
it's been just reworked with the UI in
mind it's gonna have a much easier UI
than we've seen it's gonna have all the
free updates that they've rolled out to
the PC so that's toddlers you got your
pools your careers and I have it on good
authority that future PC free updates
are also going to make the jump to ps4
so I think that's really exciting I
think what's really important here it's
not a reimagining it's not reconstituted
I think I last play the herbs on ps2 and
those things weren't quite traditional
Sims games and that's really what people
want so as Sid said exact same game but
with ps4 friendly UI that's what really
what you want and of course it's
launching with all the fan favorites
like city living and vampires except
radar you're going to be cruel to your
sins yeah I mean it starts with about
three hours of building a house and then
you just cruel to them for the rest of
it and lock them in a room so hey we're
keeping a pretty quick pace on today's
show and we've got yet another game
update to share with you right now and
Rob I got this sense you were kind of
fired up for this one I am massively
excited about this one when I first
heard this was coming out and I
literally was jumping for joy
not for anything so I believe we're
going to have a little look at tennis
world tour let's check out the trailer
right now
[Applause]
and that was a new look at tennis world
torts coming to ps4 next year Rob yeah
but I am super hype for this yeah Holly
can attest this I've been we wanting a
tennis game on ps4 forever yeah like
it's been it's been way too long since
we've had a good proper deep Tennis sim
like the last one I really got stuck
into was a topspin 4 on ps3 I played
that so much I was 100 feet away from
platinum yet and I understand some of
the deaths from tops before are working
on tennis world talk that's true and
there's gonna be I think they've got a
30 licensed players so far there's a
full-on career mode and it's really
focused on the simulation of it as well
and so if you're after that deep really
sim heavy tennis game this is gonna be
the one for you I think MLB has got it's
got some competition
well the excitement is palpable and I
want to just take a quick status check
just take a moment to catch our breath
here Playstations media showcase here at
Paris games week it's just about 30
minutes away so you know that's gonna
have some good stuff and we're gonna be
cutting live for that right after this
program and we are running a bit behind
we've got a lot to get to we've got a
lot of announcements we've got reveals
updates to share right here and I want
to kind of bring the conversation back
to PlayStation VR because it's just
celebrated its one-year birthday that's
right more than a hundred games out
there for PlayStation VR tons more due
for 2018 Ramon what's your favorite psvr
game Resident Evil yeah this scared the
living crap out of me I played the first
few minutes regular on my television and
I popped on the psvr completely
different experience I can't allow them
a scaredy cat so I tried to get the
shotgun and leave the house but they
really work out finish it we're not
going to talk about that today it's way
too scary but a game I really enjoyed
and I'm not even a massive Trekkie yeah
but I really enjoy playing a Star Trek
bridge crew we played it in the
PlayStation access office four of us all
playing you each have a different role
on the bridge like I was the helmsman
Davers the captain and you have to
really coordinate to achieve your
objectives and it's like the ultimate
wish fulfillment if you're a Star Trek
fan being able to be in Star Trek it was
just a really immersive experience
exactly what PlayStation VR is good at
amazing game you did nothing but
squabble it was a video of you Scotland
now while you like to fit you know
quietly on the bridge this is my dam
give me a go and give me giant alien
spiders and let me go to town on them
I really enjoyed Farpoint I think as
well it also had the aim controller and
I just had that feeling that if anyone
should walk into a living room when I'm
playing Farpoint I might look slightly
more badass while in my pajamas because
I've at least got the game controller
playing it in coop as well which just
means you and a friend can bicker while
you try and take on the aliens
everything I wanted very exciting but
this is this is the highlight for me the
super hot tiny sit down there in the
lower corner your screen playing
superhot VR I loved it on ps4 but on
PlayStation VR just so immersive like
we're we're all cackling like goons you
know as I do all of this like I'm
blasting these guys I'm throwing
ashtrays at them I'm throwing phones at
them dual wielding here like like some
sort of John Woo movie it's just a riot
I mean it's just pure fun so much fun
and that's sort of some of the
highlights for PlayStation VR they're
out now enough about me enough about us
and our favorite it's time to take a
look at the future of PlayStation VR
because there's a lot of great games
coming we've got two of them to share
with you right this minute so let's
check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it takes more than a fancy airship to
make it in the arena
[Music]
it takes a fearless captain and a steady
crew join today and experience
heart-stopping thrills
life or death battles
[Music]
fight alongside your heroes or take them
on
welcoming worry can be yours do you have
what it takes
[Music]
that was two brand new games revealed
for PlayStation VR both scheduled for
release in 2018 now looking at bow to
blood Rob your Star Trek bridge crew fan
I kind of thought that might be kind of
your ally I mean for me that's what
PlayStation VR is amazing at letting you
experience things that you're never
going to experience anywhere else and so
piloting a really high tech airship in
Bowser blood yes that is probably right
up my alley
like it's a really unique game as well
as setting this kind of fantasy reality
TV show we've got other contestants or
enemies and and you could betray them or
you can make allies with them and also
it's procedurally generated as well so
every time you play bow to blood you're
going to be getting a completely new
experience every time but for me it's
just you know airships airships in VR
that's what it's about for me I
absolutely love it there there's also
megalith we got a quick look at that one
Ramone what do you know that first
trailer that we saw so megalith is
actually an action-packed shooter yes
it's a hero shooter yeah so you're a
Titan trying to become a giant God has
destructible environments you give free
locomotion it's also coming out in 2018
and the development team behind it are
full of multiplayer veterans and they're
excited about what they can do in VR
which also makes all of us excited
because with VR you're gonna have
totally new experiences loads of
innovation so we can't wait to see that
everybody's gonna do absolutely and one
of the great things about PlayStation VR
is new experiences but also putting a
fresh perspective on familiar ones so in
that note let's take a look at ultra
wings VR coming - psvr
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's plenty factor my goodness I've
got the vapors I mean let me make of
that Holly I loved it it reminded me of
a mango you see really into calls Air
Gear just cuz of the rollerblading as a
game has already had tons of press
attention the deficit said no you can
comfortably run climb and flags this
very action-packed on his obstacle
courses and they has they called fluid
locomotion that is what they're indeed
and we also just checked out ultra Wings
VR that's also coming to PlayStation VR
it's an open world VR flight game lots
of courses and challenges interesting
that you use the PS moves to pilot the
craft a bunch of different crafts
they're saying thirty hours or so to get
all the gold medals so that's horribly
lost experience they're keeping it
moving on the PlayStation VR front we
actually do have an update to share
right now around a favorite that was
announced at e3 now if you watch the
three PlayStation media showcase you saw
a quirky delightful little game called
moss and we're delighted to say that
this one is actually coming out February
2018 so we could finally announce that
Ramon you got a chance to play yes I did
the developers at poly Ark was so kind
of seeing me a build and I got to play
last week
I'm loving this game so you control this
Mouse her name is quill she got this
little sword that's awesome little like
leaf thing on her arm which is kind of
cool and what's awesome about this game
is the fact that you're using the analog
sticks of control quill but when you're
doing the puzzles in 3d space you're
actually using the motion controller on
the door shock for interesting man it
looks amazing I'm right so you get to
control both both the kind of the
puzzles and quill at the same time it
exactly the exact same time I really
really love this demo that they sent me
up this game is gonna be
so awesome I can't wait to play and it's
a dungeon crawler with the little mouse
it's a little tiny mouse named well so
cute but yeah I mean I just this is one
of the things I just love about VR is
just new ways to interact I mean that's
kind of I think deep down what we all
look for in gaming and something that
PlayStation VR actually well-positioned
to provide you come back this is a first
look at some of the combat so they see
quills gonna take care of these little
red beagles so it's awesome is with the
Dual Shock you can free some of the
enemies you're doing both at the same
tactical does it feel like easy to do
both of the same yeah I didn't have I
didn't have trouble at all controlling
quill or some of the pulses at the same
time and control quill to get her to run
all the way up I would have played this
non-stop if they sent me that demo
that's awesome so this is coming out
February 2018 pre-order start very soon
Wow that's right well thank you for that
hands-on report there Ramon on Maus it's
coming February 2018 very excited about
that one here's an update on another
title that was announced for PlayStation
VR at e3 that star child we've got a
brand new trailer and there's well I'll
just leave it to the trailer let's check
it out hi everyone I'm Paul Buettner I'm
the founder and CEO at playful and I'm
kind and Pearson the director of
Starchild Starchild is a cinematic
platforming adventure game you play a
spectra a traveler who crashed lands on
an alien planet during an important
mission you're about to see one of
spectres unique abilities here today for
the first time we hope you enjoyed this
global debut of our new trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brand new trailer for starchild here we
just debuted and I gotta admit guys I'm
a little puzzled by this unique ability
any ideas more like questions she was
projecting herself out of her body and
manipulating like maybe astral
projection I want to say maybe
telekinesis
so I guess we're just gonna have to wait
and see huh so uh lots more to come here
on the show and we haven't even gotten
to the PlayStation Media showcase by the
way so we are gonna have a big final
fantasy update for you at home
we're gonna have a big update for more
VR we're gonna have more game
announcements and then of course that
PlayStation Media showcase it's coming
really really soon I want to check back
before we move on though on one of the
year's biggest PlayStation VR titles
resi 7 yeah Resident Evil 7 I mean
bigger than resi 7 on VR anything and
the exciting news is there is new free
DLC for resi 7 coming in December 399
399 is free even more exciting it stars
fan favorite Chris the muscles read for
you everyone knows Chris Redfield he's
just I mean it's gonna be an awesome you
take on the resi 7 formula and it's
entirely playable in VR again just like
the main resi seven game Redfield it's
like an action hero so it's gonna give a
really different spin on on the gameplay
to resi seven I think and we can have a
look at the trailer for the not a hero
DLC right now you'll pay for this
you're going to fail he's next in my
list
psycho
this show it's worse him or those things
[ __ ] you gotta be kidding me please tell
me what I'm looking at
oh that's different
like you haven't been since we got here
brand-new look at a resonable sevens
free not a hero DLC Rob I know you're a
big fan of Resident Evil I mean it's one
of the best of the year it is I think
it's in my top three of the year yeah I
spent the majority of Resident Evil 7
hiding and all running away from things
I think now I'm playing as Chris
Redfield I'm gonna be punching stuff in
the face right and that'll be awesome
now Ramon I'm told you're a big fan of
Halloween I most certainly am I love
Halloween actually we have two psvr
games launching in time for Halloween
let's take a look at this spooky pair
I will now teach you the ways of art
[Music]
hello
[Music]
Wow two wildly different takes on the
horror genre I guess that's fair to say
right Rob yeah I mean stifled looks
absolutely terrifying
so like nothing I've ever seen either
from from the trailer looks like you
have to kind of make noise to paint a
picture of the world around you but at
the same time that noise could attract
things that you don't quite want to be
attracting
I think we should make Dave play love
that game if you're watching Dave you're
gonna be playing stifled very soon dead
hungry also reports of a local Roco
suits me just fine I enjoy food
it's from pixel junk so you know it's
kind of gonna be crazy the idea is the
zombies are really hungry so you're
making fast food and literally loving it
at them to cure them actually we're not
trying to kill them or harm the zombies
gonna make them better it just looks
like pixel junk madness that you can
create different burgers by throwing
things together
um I'm in browser zombies I mean that's
to PlayStation VR games coming out
tomorrow in time for Halloween which is
awesome there's another PlayStation VR
game coming out very soon League of War
and I believe we can see a trailer for
that right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right that was league of war I'll
tell you those two look like they're
having the time of their lives on that
couch I mean they were just they're all
grins and smiles it's a horse play but
is it RTS or tower defense or what is it
it's a little bit of both yeah League of
War you basically can grab a tank pick
it up and drop it on the battlefield and
watch it go and blow stuff up and who
doesn't want to do that so it's gonna
have a really really nice single-player
campaign tons of different generals that
you from and I really like the use of
the social screen very cool very cool so
is that it for PlayStation VR then no
because you promised oh yeah that's
right that's right
promise me that I could talk about
monster of the deep final fantasy 15
unsurprising I'm a massive final fantasy
fan and I'm really excited to get to
show you a little bit more I've got to
play a bit of it and I got to speak to
YouTube after Stan recently as well with
PlayStation access it is furious that
before I talk about anything else it is
a standalone game you don't need own 15
it's not DLC a standalone game for
PlayStation VR so for anyone who's
played the game you'll recognize some of
the locations but I have been told
there's some new ones as well which is
quite exciting so it's a beautiful world
now just like it is in 15 it feels quite
similar to playing the fishing in 15
almost like sounds that for what the VR
you know would be further fishing in 15
different tackles baits different rods
and lines put them all together to
create the right rods for catching
different fish in different locations
differently they include a VR fish
cleaning minigame you imagine that
opposed now anyone who played Final
Fantasy 15 online beta for comrades will
recognize the character customization it
has incredible customization best RPG
hair I have seen a long time that's
important you'd expect nothing less than
Final Fantasy connoisseur Rob you know
that yes the hair is beautiful
it also features some of the characters
you'll recognize in the game you already
saw Cindy now when I spoke to tabata fan
he told me that the whole team is in it
you know ignore
not this Gladio Prompto and actually
takes place within the Final Fantasy 15
game takes place quite early on you're
basically going out you meet the guys
and they're like hey why don't you come
fishing with us you can come and camp
with us as well character customization
here is stunning I think the biggest
takeaway for this for me is a huge fan
fantasy fan is this VR game here put me
into the world in a way that not even
Final Fantasy 14 does it really allows
you at the camp with the guys you're
able to steal food off not this his
plate and he'd like try and back you
away that was like the coolest thing in
front of fans 15 the camping so to be in
that is going to be like massive wish
for for money it really was it gave me
something that fanfiction.net has never
been able really put me into the world
but it gets better I'm still allowed to
talk about Final Fantasy feel there's
more there is five fantasy 15 episode
Ignace we know it's on the way he is
best boy do not at me it's not a
discussion but I'm really excited to be
able to show a new trailer flat with
some new details and I can also reveal
that the guest composer is Yasunori
Mitsuda of Chrono Trigger which everyone
knows file fantasy and music go
hand-in-hand so I guess we should just
get going please enjoy the far fantasy
15 Ignace trailer listen well a king
cannot bleed by standing still
a king pushes onward always accepting
the consequences and never looking back
[Music]
I can't tell a bloody thing from here
let's make for the
yeah buddy he'll join me I can secure us
away to the king and the Oracle
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
see you happy one day your burdens
lifted free to live and love as you
please
[Music]
what is a world that will never let you
down why not get along here I swore an
oath to stand would not and keep him
safe
whatever it takes I will protect him
[Music]
permit me to make a suggestion rather
than follow this flotsam and float away
to a watery grave why not come what do
you say
collector pilot h4 v h 1m with the daily
accountants report
nothing but sunshine
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right that was in vector actually a
game that was announced right here
repairs games week about two years ago
Ramon what did you make of that a very
awesome game in a tradition of like
amplitude frequency a little thumper in
there it's awesome and it is coming to
ps4 yes it is now I'm sorry I'm taking
back incredible and for anybody it takes
place in Altis yeah I don't give too
much away but anyone who's played that
game chapter nine right chapter nine and
it fills in basically what happens and I
don't know if you like the ring let's
not give away any spoilers but we are
finally going to get to find out you
know a big thing about Ignace is story
that until now has been a complete
mystery I mean so it's gonna be all many
many people speculating on tumblr let's
put it that way so I can only imagine
right so uh great show so far I mean I
feel like I think we we brought some
significant updates here favorite moment
real quick to call out the Hong Kong
Massacre they yeah looked insane I can't
wait to play that yeah what about you
Holly I think there's gardens that are
never sorry I've forgotten the full name
of it Gardens between between that's on
and so I know everyone thinks I'm gonna
say far fantasy but garden between
either no there's something about that
that's my jam hit good personal deep
stories wrong it's beautiful I mean for
me it's got to be it's gotta be the
tennis but I've been I've been waiting
for a really deep good tennis game for
so long so to have tennis world tour
coming is is proper exciting and I was
you know massively hype for that gotta
say for me it's probably guacamelee too
so glad that we can get that out there
it's coming soonish it looks gorgeous
it's got the four player co-op
throughout the entire campaign it's got
enhanced chicken mechanics chickens and
the chicken is to step out of the show
right that's the why everyone's here
finger that's right that's right
so hey we are almost out of time that
big PlayStation Media showcase is right
around the corner and who's to say
what's going to happen then but we do
still have two more games that we need
to announce so what do you guys think we
should do about that I think we should
announce them
yes yeah that's my good man so let's
kick it off with the very first game
we're gonna be announcing and we'll do
that right now
[Music]
and that was a first look at arrey arrey
by the way is how that's pronounced if
you were wondering uh really just
magnificent gorgeous looking game and
it's actually coming out a little later
today on PlayStation Store
Oh rate out to day there you go saving
and saving it beautiful I thought it was
incredible to look I got real journey
absolutely at vibe from it that's it's
totally again my kind of thing I really
believe with with gaming for me
personally I was very triple-a only I
never really considered indie and then I
started adding that in and I feel like I
always compare it to having a balanced
diet yeah Gaming diet balanced gaming
diet and these are the kind of games for
me the balance it out so in this
particular game you're exploring the
world's a child that can turn into a
dragon you've already seen that in some
of the easy sell isn't it I mean it's
really yourself the idea is there are
these Titans within the world and they
have very important jobs but for some
reason they've stopped doing their job
so you're trying to convince them to
basically go back to work but by doing
it going through the world solving
puzzles exploring there are mysteries
within the world for you to uncover as
well I think it's beautiful and I'm so
excited that it's actually gonna be
available you know today today you you
love the look of this then you can pick
it up by now what you said about journey
and absolute is I think on point really
getting those kind of vibes from it I
think it's just so nice to see games
like this as well coming out and if you
know if you're looking at this and you
guys don't play in these I was the same
as you please just if one of them ago
maybe you'll discover a whole new
library of games what's wrong with that
right nothing wrong with it at all I
mean that is beautiful so a that was
array and I got to say you know I think
we had a lot to talk about here tonight
and I want to thank actually all the
independent developers all the
publishers who worked with us to put
this show together it's an honor for us
to be able to debut and your titles and
to be able to provide all these
meaningful updates and just exciting
stuff all around but I got to say that
PlayStation Media Showcase is right
around the corner
I want to make a shout out though to
everyone watching live we've got a lot
more to come after the showcase at the
showcase ends there's more to come we're
gonna dive deeper into all those games
that you saw a PlayStation showcase all
the new stuff you see they're excited
guys I mean massively excited yeah these
moments where we all come together that
the audience is already in you can feel
the electricity I already know from
people watching at home as well cuz they
have absolutely no idea it could be
anything it's like a big sporting event
like it's the kind of nerves you feel
like ready to see something epic and
amazing and who knows I mean it's just
it's literally a couple of minutes from
now and we're gonna be cutting through
that live here in just just a couple of
minutes but first we do have one other
thing we wanted to share with you this
is one I've been dying to talk about all
night long but I've had to restrain yes
right you could talk about it now in
just a handful of seconds from now we're
going to talk about and show first
details on a brand new game that's from
a independent studio and that's the it's
a new title from a developer that's
actually rather celebrated so I would
suggest that we cut to that now and for
all of you watching at home enjoy the
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
samurai you are warrior
I can see that
you trained your whole life for this and
you have won battles but lesser men have
called unwinnable yes but while you were
shopping in your sword do you know how I
prepared for today I learned I know your
language your traditions your beliefs
which villages to tame
rooster blood so I'll ask you once again
samurai do you sit in that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome M
Ryan
Wow what a great way to open Paris games
week thank you for joining us tonight
it's now five years since we launched a
Playstation 4 and I still have the honor
to in vail a brand new triple a game the
astonishing ghost of Tsushima from
sucker punch
and you know what that's not the less
surprise that you're about to get you've
seen the power of PlayStation 4 provides
you not only with immersive storytelling
but also allows developers to fulfill
their wildest dreams the great news is
that these developers are now extracting
more and more power from the machine
with increasingly spectacular results
that's why a single creative mind like
toby fox can deliver one of the year's
biggest hits in undertale why a small
studio like Ninja Theory can take you on
a thrilling personal journey with
triple-a production values in hell-blade
and our own worldwide Studios can bring
alive horizon zero dawn breathtaking
wilderness in dynamic 4k resolution and
HDR furthermore you can expect
innovative new dimensions in gameplay as
we continue to explore the possibilities
of virtual reality the bottom line is
that there is so much power and
potential packed into PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation 4 pro that innovation will
continue to accelerate and proliferate
in the coming months and years with more
than 225 games offering graphical
enhancements on PlayStation 4 Pro and
more than a hundred games compatible
with PlayStation VR PlayStation is
already the best place to play as we
will show you tonight it's thrilling to
think there's even more to come while we
continue to focus on bringing you the
games you love we're also focused on
expanding the PlayStation community
we're excited about innovation like play
linked highly social easy to play
localized and fun we've been thrilled
with the success of that's you with over
3 million downloads to date and see more
social and family orientated games give
ease an opportunity to expand our reach
and amplify our mission
the the best place to play the past 20
years have seen trends come and trends
go we're still here stronger than ever
and well positioned for the future the
ecosystem of today will be more powerful
more engaging and more immersive
tomorrow the maturity of the gaming
industry is an incredible asset to a
dynamic and exciting future for
Playstation ultimately words mean little
action is everything and the proof is in
the journey into the extraordinary
worlds of new titles and new experiences
that you're about to enjoy I think
you'll agree that the best place to play
just keeps getting better so let's take
a look at some of the most sought after
exclusive content our industry has ever
seen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been watching you Erica I've been
watching you for a very long time
that you've been watching you too
they have been waiting very patiently
and now they have come for you
[Music]
just remember
don't break a seal
[Music]
if you break the seal
my god collective
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take
[Music]
Julie
[Music]
the world has changed it's been ripped
apart by an unknown force
[Music]
[Music]
the games begin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come to see what's biting have you my
name is Ryan Marx I left London to be a
soldier but then there came from my
family
now I'm back when everything just got a
little bit complicated Batman for a joke
off I don't want a demon over a bar
getting closer and closer yes your
resolve them quick no clamoring here
it's just stammering three I'm on my
team won't quit I'm a real Batman I got
Batman
start talking more [ __ ] dead wait
listen it was all his idea
writers get out that
it's PlayStation VR mocks its first year
in the market it's really moving to see
how development teams are starting to
see the raw power of this game-changing
technology we're witnessing the birth of
new styles of gaming storytelling and
visceral experiences the future of
PlayStation VR is extremely bright and
we look forward to unveiling more in the
near future one of the consistent
factors in our success over the four
generations of consoles has been the
unwavering support of our partners we
were delighted to feature a massive
amount of indie and VR content in the
pre-show and now it's time to showcase
six games all of which offer features
and benefits unique to PlayStation from
some of our most valued partners all of
whom we've been working with from the
very beginning let's start with a new
trailer from our friends at Ubisoft
[Music]
good Eden's gain is still causing
trouble
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Guardian what I'm about to tell you
stays between us while we have been
fighting an ancient gate has opened on
Mercury and the army of past and future
machines and
they intend to reshape the universe in
their image but there is one
since this dark future he was my mentor
Osiris the most notorious guardian event
once his dangerous ideas
and he was banished
now he has returned
bring us
you are the one thing they have not
foreseen go to mercury and find Osiris
time is not on our side
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
turns out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Walter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by the season passing at the Carrington
bonus net
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the umpires time masks
thank you to all our partners it's a
real privilege to have your titles on
our platform a key differentiator for
PlayStation is its best-in-class
development teams that make up worldwide
studios we have a great lineup of
exclusive games coming soon only on
PlayStation 4 let's take a look behind
bars what's next
the city's safer than ever maybe Peter
Parker can have more life
are you in trouble do you need no no I
mean I'm a little behind on my rent but
no I take care of this place it
represents best part of me smiles it's
gonna be helping out your city and
everything you care about will be
destroyed people will make you for help
but you won't be able to say
[Music]
please just
[Music]
maybe the city needs our friend what do
you think
Oh anyone else need a breather
[Applause]
[Music]
you've been gone for two weeks so the
place is a mess
do the housework wash it you cook the
meals that's Alice you look after her
homework bath all that crap got it right
away
[Music]
are you going to school today
[Music]
I'm sure we used to be friends before I
was reset maybe we can be friends again
[Music]
you shouldn't mess around with my stuff
it makes me nervous I'm sorry baby you
think this de maybe you think it's my
fault your [ __ ] mother took off
back here you see there
Alice daddy's very mad
[Music]
[Music]
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that kills us that's it no violin Noel
no afterlife ever it does not attack mom
made them some more dangerous than that
then do not drop your guard
[Music]
follow me yes sir that doesn't sound
like a soul eater
[Music]
what do you think it is you shall see
boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hopefully we've made one thing clear to
you tonight it's a great time to be a
gamer to close the show let's have the
first in-depth look at a
much-anticipated an exclusive title from
everyone a Playstation thank you for
your continued support good night
[Applause]
[Music]
are nested with sin
reason that they may know
Yura
where is the other apostate
clip her wings
[Applause]
your demons are coming cut her down
she's one of them left
watch your backs
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm the one that makes people see
standoffish
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and so we're back from Paris we traveled
across the ocean and now we're here here
in San Francisco that was an exciting
journey that was pretty good I got off
to well you know is the pre-show I
couldn't expect too much from it
yeah the pre-show I was really worried
cuz I thought the pre-show was gonna be
like just full of new game announcements
and excitement yeah that was that was
not a hyped way to start well okay
guacamelee to to kick things off maybe
not everyone's idea yeah of like a huge
big release but first of all Camila was
a really really good game so I'm
actually really pleased like I love that
yes super beautiful very expressive the
game had a pretty good sense of humor as
well kept it all light-hearted
throughout despite some really
challenging platforming stuff this looks
to be more of the same they were making
a big deal about new chicken abilities
just show a trailer and then move on to
the next I think it's safe to say we can
expect more of what made the first game
great for us the thing that was most
exciting about the pre-show spelunky to
know I'm one of those people that didn't
quite fall in love with spelunky - I
think it's a respectable game but it
just didn't bite me so explain why are
you so excitin though we look the same I
feel like we're just polar opposites of
people like so spelunky - like moss
mouth the developer of the game like I
wouldn't have expected them to go back
to - spelunky but right the thing that
makes spelunky so amazing is the depth
there it's not just that it's a
platformer and it's not just as
personally generated like yeah it's cool
and it works well as a game it's that it
has these layers of of hidden secrets
these like it's there's so much
knowledge you need to know yeah like it
doesn't feel like just a game that you
it's one and done where you just play
through and you experience it it's it's
a game that you just keep coming back to
it's a star - vally got it kind of or
like a game that you don't just play and
then put down it's a game that you keep
coming back to and you keep learning a
discovering new things about and that's
why that's like really exciting to think
like that level of detail and that that
level of secrecy that will be put back
into another spelunky game I I'm hyped
yeah
it is cool I didn't actually believe
that we'd ever see another spooling he
came because it seemed like everyone who
liked the first one thought it was that
was it didn't need anymore but Kevin you
is surprising us with a new one so happy
for folks maybe I'll get a chance this
time around so the thing that was not
surprising and as we said earlier there
was a lot of VR just kind of spread out
tons of new both new VR games and
updates to games we've we've kind of
seen what do you think are you re are
you excited more for VR or do you feel
like I mean no I'm still not over pushed
over the edge but to see I think Moss is
maybe the one game that stands out to me
the most just because it's got a little
rabbit the lure the mouse yeah cuz it's
got a lot of character and it kind of
reminds me of the red wall series of
books which I think you and I talk about
every once in a while
Starchild is a game that is supposed to
be I don't know the devs talked about it
like it was very interesting and then
they had an interesting new mechanic to
show us but I couldn't really tell what
that was taking over mechs I so many of
those games kind of ran into one another
and I don't like that you have this
shootie game where you're running around
shooting it's a lot of the expected
stuff ultra wings VR did kind of give me
pilot wings vibes which was kind of nice
to see cuz I really liked pilot wings
but there's so much about that well at
least the Super Nintendo game that I
don't know if that's some people to
translate from another developer on this
platform with a lot of shooting type
stuff I don't know and so they also did
another play link title which we haven't
spent a lot of time with here on the
site right but those are games that you
play with your phone and this one seems
like it's gonna be very story driven
which yes like I don't democratic
storytelling I'm not a huge fan of that
but is this more single-player that you
just play with your phone because it
doesn't feel like that's democratic
storytelling does not seem like it works
with something like this I'm pretty sure
it's multiplayer voting to see what
happens I am NOT super excited for that
was there was there anything that really
stood out on the the VR side that you
were like I mean not necessarily the
moss
I mean moss yes moss looks very cute
looks like
a lot of character but again maybe
nothing thing that's gonna push me over
the edge
the the dead hungry VR game it seemed a
little iffy despite carrying the pixel
junk name it's kind of really it's hard
to tell what makes that game special if
anything there was ultra wings which was
just pilot wings with guns welcome to
two minutes ago let's talk about that's
fine yeah I mean unsurprisingly the VR
showing isn't that strong and they're
trying real hard to sell it what are
they gonna do I don't know so one thing
that I thought was interesting nobody
commented on it because of course you're
not gonna comment on this none of those
titles said PlayStation Vita he is dead
he's dead dead that's safe to say waka
me like like guacamole not on
PlayStation Vita right yeah so we're
that's Sony just quietly saying yeah
we're done with that but so we went
through the pre-show and then it started
the real show and that's how we knew I
alright so so this is not all just gonna
be kind of smaller announcements because
we started off with sucker-punches new
game yeah ghost of Tsushima I believe
which looks I mean it's hard to tell
exactly what it is just yet but the
setting looks promising the the sort of
dialogue we were hearing from the
character sounds drama drama heavy so
yeah I mean a foreboding samurai
adventure where presumably you'll be put
up against seemingly impossible odds
sounds good
I'm paper yeah and now that's also
something that we talked about in the
pre-show that I we are gonna see new IP
and we're gonna see a lot of CG trailers
right doesn't give us a lot to go on as
far as unfortunately is this good is
this interesting yeah I mean we can we
can look at the people involved and you
know keep our fingers crossed that's a
good sign but we will have to wait and
see with this like minigames yes the
trailer looks really cool it does decide
about the trailer yeah so after the
montage of again VR games that we saw we
got another look at Far Cry 5
particularly focused on the top stuff
yeah I'm just like a lot of questions
about this game I guess I'm just really
curious how the setting is going to meld
with everything they're trying to do the
setting meaning the story as they said
the Midwest America
yeah it it polluted seem like it's gonna
be difficult
yeah for something that is just kind of
blow [ __ ] up fun which is kind of what
Far Cry is like you end up with your
friends just do cost complete mayhem
yeah but that's coming out what we got
February next year and this one I
believe yeah most of this stuff is is it
seems like early 2018 and a lot of stuff
that was announced for the end of this
year which is a little bit crazy there
was a game announced for today that
everyone thought was journey to for the
first few minutes are a re or or a or a
aurait not quite sure what that one is
it looks like I mean as they were at the
hosts were describing it's got a bit of
a Abzu kind of journey vibe so a you
know quiet very personal journey well I
guess I'm gonna be checking that out
later today see what's up with that a
few other I guess that was probably it
for stuff coming out this year right
well I guess any - yes me too
I'm not coming out this year but no it's
not I mean not December it's a game the
tortilla its DLC the curse of Osiris is
coming out December 5th so you got on
the detonator you were not a destiny one
player no you jumped on destiny - yes
and I've already jumped off but you're
305 no not quite 280 but I look if I can
have more of a narrative things that
farmers own like that he'll that he'll
oh my god get those vex yay I stopped
caring about this game and now that
you've gone new helm
I want it that's just the thing right I
think for me I kind of fell off the
train because it looks like they were
just sort of giving away everything that
was great through xur and it was really
easy to get everything in the game - the
iron banner stuff which proved to be a
real pain in the butt oh I hate it when
the game lets you get stuff I wish
everything was behind Impala oh I'm
wrong well look my motivations
disappeared let's say but this will
bring me back in yeah then they moved on
to monster world
monster hunter world monster worlds of
Hunter yeah so I I we might have a
preview going up for this pretty soon
where we get to talk about a little bit
but I have not seen any of this all of
this is new too
and we got to see a lot of new monsters
in this trailer and they are pretty epic
you're gonna have to talk to this one
because this is your busier bag so I'm
I'm excited four months or a hundred
world both because it looks really good
it there there's I think still a high
barrier to entry right and that's one of
the things Monster Hunter has to answer
is like how are you going to on board
new players without making your current
fanbase feel like it's too easy feel
like you're just pandering to the you
know a more mainstream audience so it'll
be curious I'm curious to see how they
answer those kind of questions but as
far as delivering epic battles against
badass looking monsters like Monster
Hunter World Monster Hunter series is
still the one that does that they have
competitors like dauntless which look
interesting and you have that whole
online aspect but as far as creating
these creatures that just look crazy to
fight that are so in both intimidating
and exciting to chase after Monster
Hunter worlds the one that delivers yeah
I'd love to get into this I got to see a
little bit at TGS and we played with I
think the game's director and he was you
know more or less showing us everything
that you can do in the game and by that
I mean he was helping us through a
mission that we could not handle as
amateurs very difficult game to get into
but very promising as well lots of
different ways to interact with the
environment and coordinate with your
teammates who were doing the same thing
but likely different things it's
complicated
the DLC is something that I always loved
so the earlier almost hundred games have
had not all my recent monster hundred
games have had fun crossover DLC like
Mega Man costumes for your calicos this
one will have horizon zero dawn where
you play as alloy or at least you put on
her Arbor Eloi Eloi yeah they get around
the alloy joke reference I'm still a
joke embarrassingly I still need to play
horizon zero um yes you do so I will
play that before the end of the year
because we have a lot of Game of the
Year stuff coming up yes this is
something that I think looks really cool
this actually made me more excited to
try out some horizon because it's gonna
be a monster hunter as well yeah and
there's gonna be a beta coming on
December 9th Oh excellent
so I sound clear whether that's gonna be
just on PlayStation 4 or whether that's
gonna be across every platform but so
you'll get a chance to
try that out pretty soon then other
stuff we show a lot of trailers for
stuff we've seen before like Call of
Duty World War 2 but that was fir I
think DLCs showing off right resistance
the resistance yeah I didn't quite get a
whole lot out of the trailer cuz I just
assumed it was a trailer free game
that's coming out next week by the time
at the end it was like oh look new DLC
coming and this coming it's weird to see
DLC for something that I haven't even
played yet that's not even out right
like just pretend that you haven't
already finished the DLC for the game
that's coming up like I know that the
like I know with the production schedule
like that's not necessarily how it all
works out but it's weird to see DLC when
I haven't even touched sure but for some
people that's an easy way to you know
justify a sale battlefront 2 as well
mm-hmm Star Wars Battlefront 2 but I did
they didn't show the DLC for that yet
cuz we really haven't seen anything of
that game know so getting into the story
and the multiplayer we played a little
bit with some of the betas coming out
yeah I then spider-man which still looks
really great
it looks really action-packed I'm still
not totally sold on the action side of
things in terms of combat we've sold a
story I'm sold on the direction of the
cutscenes it looks like a thing I'd
enjoy watching if not if not playing but
I'll give it a shot for sure and we saw
again a little bit of the things that we
saw from e3 expanded on a little bit
things like Detroit did anything stand
up for me for that Detroit become human
no I know I know I know I know I'm
trying to like yes where you play as
David cage I know I'm like I'm ready to
send get too excited about this game
because I have played dedicates games
before and they're not always for me
like I enjoy the little bite-sized
vignettes that you get and this seems to
be like a rather tense one but how this
all plays into the bigger picture like
in previous games you know if it's I
don't know if it's gonna have the glue
to really hold everything together the
way I'd want so I absolutely I'm
cautiously optimistic about this let's
say I'll play it God aboard you were
more excited about in the pre-show
watching it it now seeing knowing it's
coming early 2018 seeing the kid I'm
worried about the kid I'm worried the
kid's gonna get a little annoying no
it's like The Last of Us - it's like
having a buddy who's gonna help you out
but he's not gonna get in the way but
that's presuming that the characters
written as well
and acts as well and manages its himself
as well what does it say needs to take
care of [ __ ] so the thing that I think
looked really good we got to see more of
Shadow of the Colossus a remake it
almost doesn't look like it's in the
Last Guardian engine like it feels so
detailed in so realistic and not that
the last kardea didn't look great but
like this looks even better it seems
slightly different for sure and yeah I'm
very excited for this as well still in
fact I think this you know maybe it has
me a little bit more hyped this new
trailer there is there anything that we
that wasn't a part of the original game
that you can glean from this that we
didn't get to play before it looks like
it's added on not that I'm aware of and
from what I've heard like you know there
were some hidden bosses in the game that
never made it to the finished product
and I've heard that those will not be in
here as well they sent an interview I
think from a couple weeks ago I hope I'm
right about that as far as I'm aware
it's it's just translating the you know
game that we knew over one to one I'd be
shocked if they tried to take too many
liberties with this one just because of
the legacy of the game and obviously you
know oh wait his work is so revered
among fans I don't think they'll have
the hidden like I don't know they were
hidden bosses I think they were just
like areas that were never completed and
didn't have a creature living in them
like I assume those will just be taken
out there were just things that weren't
finished in the game or just didn't work
right exactly yeah no I think this is
gonna be just what we what we expect
alright so the last thing that we saw
was a trailer for a game and there was
so much arguing here in the office over
what is whether it was days gone or the
Last of Us - and I was on the fence
until and until it started getting a
little bit more stealthy and then it was
like no this is the Last of Us - and of
course it is this was a trailer for the
Last of Us - with characters we have
never seen before right what the hell do
you think is going on
hard to know there's some sort of like
group that seems to be tied to religion
or some sort of philosophy and they're
they're taking up people as sacrifice
sort of like cleanse them of sin or
something it's very difficult to tell
this new character is she is she's super
buff pick my words right out of my mouth
but then we also see her being
skewed from that certain doom by Delhi
by L le is often that's totally le
shooting the arrows it wasn't that the
the kid the shaved head oh no you're
right with an arrow
I totally that's my brain just doesn't
function
lets-a-go I totally forgot I still think
Ellie's around here though yes I
wouldn't be surprised just watching
it's hard to glean a lot from this other
than hey the game's making progress and
the cutscenes to look pretty good and of
course doing the thing that works best
in zombie films that it's not just you
versus zombies its versus some [ __ ] up
humans right side like that that
conflict is always much more interesting
than just fighting waves of zombies and
that's the thing that the last of us got
so good so well what they did right yeah
this doesn't have this sort of like get
out of jail free card where she has the
knife to her belly and then like uh
noise distracts the person from
finishing the kill I don't always buy
that that's I feel like she'd be like
hold on let me just cut this real quick
well they do this but then they cut like
cuz this seems real like I don't want to
watch this happen and then you just
watch somebody get their arms smashed
inside elbow joint just hammer its
crushed this pretty brutal yeah alright
but that's that's pretty exciting and
that's I think a lot coming up for
PlayStation in both 2017 but especially
2018 yeah how hyped are you for for
PlayStation 4 in 2018 do you think this
is gonna be a year that they continue to
dominate or do you think like Xbox one
or Nintendo switch can still kind of
step up to that I I need to say who's
going to like really lead the pack here
it's tough to say we put it this way
there's enough games that I know I'll
continue using my PlayStation on a
regular basis but I haven't seen
anything for next year that that's
really just sort of making me crazy
excited just yet
I think that'll come maybe wants to get
time to play these games rather than
just watch trailers well so if you did
miss anything if you want to recap all
these trailers all the news you can
check that out on GameSpot calm we have
a rundown with everything that you might
have missed and that's about it for us
and the show thanks so much for watching
that was Peter Brown don't have just
inhaled